on va accueillir tous et yassine
belattar pour la déroute
[Applaudissements]
avec jean bessière au latran soir c'est
pour le transport pour le transport ont
ils à des copains si je t'aime beaucoup
tu le sais je sais je suis un ami hier
déjà des pmp c'était chaud mais avant
même que ça commence tu a téléphoné à
une femme très importante brigitte macro
mois la galerie des cyril hanouna on
était sur le plateau ont pensé à vous
avec un grand v victoire brigitte voulez
vous embrasser ou dire bon anniversaire
plein de bonnes choses j'ai fait livrer
une table de ping pong à l'elysée
j'espère qu'elle va arriver bientôt
mais non c'est acquis un tel niveau de
confiance incroyable sur d'autres
chaînes à la même heure on fait des
karaokés
mais nous sur ces vite on appelle la
première dame de france
en plus il laisse des messages avec les
chroniqueurs qui lui chante joyeux
anniversaire mais cyril franchement je
m'en vais te le dire mais elle travaille
cette dame elle a des activités
importantes imagine au même moment elle
était en train de parler d'un truc hyper
important regarde c'était d'être
présente aussi avec vous aujourd'hui
c'est aussi pour porter la parole à
celles et ceux qui n'ont jamais pu la
prendre
celles et ceux qui n'ont jamais osé
s'exprimer par peur de représailles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pense que tant que tu as pas repris
un redressement fiscal sur 15 ans et
calmera jamais jean castex premier
ministre de la sixième puissance
mondiale soit 7000 67 millions
d'habitants voilà comment lui par cyril
hanouna traces et surtout les personnes
et qui vont aux nerfs nous profiter de
plateaux repas végétariens formation des
collèges les bus d'iveco jamais vu un
mec annoncé çà comme çà il ya un cap
janot avec m
volo volo janot et sa paille
certains sont allés en prison pour moi
que ça ne c'est pas grave j'ai hâte de
voir tes pmp en corée du nord
cyril dans les débats sur les
restaurants clandestins tu as reçu un
invité qui est venu témoigner
anonymement
est ce qu'on peut voir la photo du mec
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un mec il met des lunettes de soleil
devient de nîmes
ça veut dire que lui alors un ami se
faire arrêter par la police et on les
dit oui calme-toi il dit je suis maître
gims pas du tout et moi je suis là crime
voilà je sais qu'on n'a pas d'oreille
dans cette émission les chroniqueurs
peuvent témoigner
ouais mais on pourrait quand même
flouter les visages s'il suffit de
mettre des lunettes de soleil pour être
anonymes présents moi si je fais ça
vas-y alors quand je lis ici demandez
moi aussi j'suis assez matin c'est
yassine belattar ou pas du tout chirac
team et je fais des sandwichs aux
mureaux c'est vrai que l anonymat quand
même un comble alors qu'est ce que c'est
que ça mes chroniqueurs ah ça c'est là
qu'est tout c'est une polémique a parlé
tout à l'heure
voilà à cause d'un tweet regarder le
tweet ça c'est énorme ça voilà gros
sweats et si vous avez déjà bu un litre
d'aujourd'hui certains y ont vu de
l'islamophobie
parce que c'était le premier jour du
ramadan alors les temps sont durs pour
les musulmans mais faut pas voir de
l'islamophobie partout des tags sur une
mosquée à rennes islamophobie une pub
pour l'eau pendant le ramadan pas
islamophobie et surtout ne donnez pas de
grain à moudre à ceux qui passent leur
temps à faire monter la levure de la
haine
merci merci beaucoup merci
six mois la cible
[Applaudissements]